you're out there fighting with angelina
jolie it's like what else do you need
why not
the eternals are a group of superheroes
who have been around for at least 7 000
years created by the celestials sent to
earth to protect humankind from the
deviants fighting
to prevent the end of the world or the
end of human civilization as we know it
so i don't think the stakes get much
higher than that
[Music]
for me to be an eternal
has many different meanings as the
character it gives me a sense of duty
because i'm in charge of the mission and
personally
it gives me
a sense of hope for change i am latino
and also arab and also in my 50s it
would have been almost unimaginable that
i would become a superhero now
i feel like what it means to be an
eternal is becoming a reflection of
people who have been here and i think
that the eternals let people have an
insight into how wonderful humankind has
been
if i could i would only work with chloe
job from here on out if chloe called me
and was like hey i'm just going to put
you in everything i do i would be like
great it's an incredible group that came
together to make this film we all come
from very different backgrounds and
cultures and it's an amazing mix of
people once we finally came together
we're all in our super suits and got to
see each other it was the most amazing
amazing experience i think i cried like
i think like i think i cried and
it still is one of the most memorable
moments i've ever had
it's like a big family everyone was
lovely and a big movie of that scale is
a bit intimidating to go on to chloe was
our captain she listened and took my
ideas on building the action
great teamwork great communication i was
very happy
[Music]
she shows her primary super strength to
be a speedster
but also very intelligent
i think that's combination of both of
those makes makari very powerful
how am i alike or different from micros
well very different i can't fly i can't
shoot lasers with my eyes i don't have
super strength all of the things i would
very much like to have my character
although she's an alien and doesn't have
any children has a very strong sense of
motherhood for the rest of the eternals
and i i have always had that
she likes to boss people around and i
have always had that too
she's a free spirit she's very loyal i
would say i have quite a lot of overlap
with
with her actually
[Music]
one of my favorite moments to shoot i
suppose was a
was filming in camden in london where i
was on a crane on wires and i'm flying
and landing on the street and that was
kind of
uh it was really fun just because i'm
above the bridge in camden and you get
to see this kind of bird's eye view of
streets that have walked for many years
so i got to see it from a different
angle i am excited to see the spectacle
and the big action pieces and also the
kind of more intimate character driven
beats as well
this is an incredibly epic movie i mean
the scale of it the story of it is
unlike anything i think marvel has ever
done before as far as ensembles go this
is one of the best ensembles i've ever
been with you know it was incredibly
emotional ride which i think the viewer
will experience when they watch it
because it's thousands of years in the
making
[Music]